Martin Maher author of the book the
greatest ever bank robbery the collapse
of the Savings and Loan industry on page
308 this sentence jumped out at me when
I read your book a little thing like 500
billion will not stop Washington from
doing business as usual especially if
the business is technical enough not to
interest the producers of the nightly
news what is that all about well I then
give a list of little favors that have
been done to people in this context
since all of this scandal came out one
would think that they would that they
would stop I mean look we have an
example recently of the federal National
Mortgage Association putting into the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development a request to do something
with a bunch of SNL's which would have
involved these SNL's getting some cash
money up front which the owners could
put in their pockets and taking a loss
on the sale of paper which they wouldn't
have to show as a loss on their books
but which they could show on as a loss
in their return to the IRS very cleverly
designed designed by an agency of the
federal government really I mean partly
it's privately owned but their five
directors appointed by the president and
it's supposed to have a social purpose
so here you've got an agency of the
government in effect doing something
which is legal it's legal we got some
very dumb laws still but which is
directly contrary to the public policy
of the S&L bailout bill that is that
bill maybe in its part there was a an
intent in that bill and here is an
effort federal National Mortgage
Association to circumvent the intent of
that bill to encourage once again
fraudulent bookkeeping at SNL and this
is now more than a year after presumably
there was a bailout and after this got
incidentally the letter of submission to
HUD said that this should be kept
completely secret and not even available
through Freedom of Information Act
request because it had it had probe
proprietary competitive you can't write
a data that might be of value to
competitors I mean this sort of sleaze
sleaze from a from an agency of the
government I don't know how you stop it
I can't stopped it by the way Kemp
wouldn't give it to them
the regulator but it it's constant this
place sells influence it sells ways to
get around the Lord writes the laws and
then sells ways to get around and I find
that's what's really disturbing to me
about this whole story is the
involvement of people who are presumably
leaders in their professions leaders in
their occupation ah in finding ways in
which you could help crooks find a
corner of the law in which you could say
that what they were doing was not
against the law
we're dealing with people who lead great
law firms four five six hundred loyal
offers great accounting firms thousands
of accountants who will work with a
crook the man that they know to be a
crook I mean some I like David Paul and
Sandra said that question when you met
David Paul wouldn't trust him around the
corner um and and that they would they
would help this guy because he was
willing to pay their fees which were
enormous fees and because they could
find a way that what he wanted to do
could maybe be on a number of legal
that's disgusting that's the worst part
of the story
not that they were Cowboys who stole
money not that they were congressmen who
took money but they're people in Wall
Street and investment houses and law
firms me accounting firms made
themselves unindicted co-conspirators
because there was money in it for them
and not only that used every ounce of
political influence they had to prevent
Congress from cleaning up the mess that
had been made in 81-82 when the governor
was trying to solve a problem took the
wrong step and then because so many
people were making money out of the
governments mistake he couldn't change
it year after year
that's what's shocking but I don't know
whether I counted right but I think I
counted twenty two books of fiction a
nonfiction three books of fiction had
probably roughly right that's
twenty-five this makes your twenty-six
book that's probably right yeah
including I've I've helped people write
memoirs my name isn't on them because
they are responsible for them and I'm
not but I've not been an invisible ghost
I've been thanked to help Rudolf being
of the Metropolitan Opera and saw Linda
woods here and George Moore who was the
first head of Citicorp worked with them
on memoirs but you know that's what I do
for living I write ok well that's why I
wanted to ask you because there's some
some things that you did in this book
you talked about today
ask you about it are you basically a
writer oh yes no I I'm trained in
economics as far as this book is
concerned yeah I wrote a book called the
bankers in 1975 I wrote a book called
the builders in 1978 David Stockman read
them and when the Reagan team came in
they asked me to join the Housing
Commission the National Housing
Commission they were setting up to
investigate housing program we were you
know we were suckered the aim of this
was to was was to cut the housing budget
and we all thought we were going to
design a new housing program they were
very decent guys unless they got I think
they were all Republicans except me
but they were all people who wanted to
do something about housing whereas the
people who would put us up to this
really just wanted to cut the budget and
they succeed I mean they really gutted
the housing program so we were we were
suckered but I was there when these regs
on the SNL's were first being written
and I was conscious that there was a
problem from the beginning but it never
occurred to me that our system was so
inflexible that having made these
mistakes you would be unable to correct
you said that you were the only one that
wasn't a Republican does that make you a
Democrat I'm yeah I'm I'm a registered
Democrat I had been a registered
independent I may have been a registered
independent when they when they put me
on the Housing Commission I'm air I my
wife died i remarried i remarried an
ardent democrat so i registered
Democratic I don't think she would have
married me if I wasn't a registered
Democrat do you consider yourself to be
a political person I consider myself to
be pretty thorough particularly in this
book I think I'm pretty thoroughly non
non partisan there is there you can't
prefer one party over the other in this
story they both misbehaved abominably
that's one of the reasons it never
became a political issue because each of
them was scared of what the other one
would be able to say about them if they
if they made it politically there are a
lot of people you talk about let me just
ask you about one dick Pratt yeah Pratt
Richard Richard Pratt is the most able
man was ever chairman of the Federal
Home Loan Bank board he came into the
Federal Home Loan Bank board which was
the body that chartered SNL's and also
owned and operated the Federal Savings
and Loan Insurance Corporation which
insured people's deposits and SNL's
he came into it at a time when the
industry had a terrible prop
he very cleverly designed a number of
accounting devices he and his his friend
as general counsel Tom White a nyan and
some of the accountants around the Bank
board they designed a system by which
this industry could pretend it was
making money when it was losing money
and this was done while I was hanging
around here a lot of these rigs came
over my desk and as early as December 81
I printed in the book I wrote a slightly
disjointed piece for a magazine called
financier in which I said we are
encouraging all these guys to lie about
the condition of their institutions
given that the interest rates are up to
sixteen seventeen percent it may be
necessary to do that not if they tell
the truth about their institutions and
they'll be the only people who do that
if the interest rates stay they were all
broke anyway so there may be some excuse
but let's remember what we did it was
going to be very costly in retrospect
this was a bad idea off the top if you
were going to do what you should have
sunset all of these regs and had them
ended a time certain so that you weren't
piling up exponentiating the losses in
this industry and but even so in
fairness to the world Pratt Pratt left
all of the odor of accomplishment dick
is a very good guy and he's I'm sure
he's furious with me
let me go back before you get into
actually just couple a little question
these aren't a little bit the Federal
Home Loan Bank board right he ran that
he was the channel the Federal Home Loan
Bank well why are you a professor
University of Utah 1981 1982
how'd it into into the spring of 83 okay
you told us a little bit of what that
does how many members are on that board
three who appoints them president is it
does it still exist no it was it was put
out of business by the wide array of the
financial institutions reorganization
and regulation enforcement agency
something like that the Act that was
passed in August of 1989 there is there
is now something called an office of
Thrift Supervision which is part of the
Treasury Department just as the office
of the control of the currency as part
of the Treasury Department the office of
Thrift Supervision charters and
regulates savings and loans the office
of the comptroller of the currency
charters and regulates banks okay I hate
keep doing this but in the beginning of
your book you list what
Fredi all these guys all these jenny-may
all these things I'm hoping to bring
people if not up to speed you know up to
cruising in this in these waters anyway
I don't want to dwell on it but the
Federal Home Loan Bank board was
physically located here in Washington
yes indeed under what Department at that
point it was it was an independent
agency of government like the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation and it it
owned the Federal Savings and Loan
Insurance Corporation the three
directors of that the the the three
board members of that were the three
members of Federal Home Loan Bank board
and it also owned the Federal Home Loan
Mortgage Corporation which packaged
mortgages and into pass-throughs and
sold them through these were all under
the bank board all right the Bank board
got its three members by the president
of resident appointed them they had to
be approved by the Congress they had to
be approved by the Congress how old was
the Federal Home Loan Bank board it goes
by it's a it goes back to the Roosevelt
era and I guess it's 34 was leave was
the first appointment of the Federal
Home Loan Bank board it grew out of the
homeowners Loan Corporation and various
ways to try to keep the lenders to
housing alive during the early years of
the depression you said that the Federal
Savings and Loan Insurance Corporation
was under that's right sorry also called
physical physically all right I'm beg
you of what yeah where did physic get
its money to ensure the savings and
loans Basel it got its money by a
premium charge on the savings and loans
themselves it also had a line of credit
of seven hundred and fifty million
dollars at the Treasury if it ever had
to borrow money in theory that was all
the resources it had when I was on the
Housing Commission and the SNL's were
losing money we got very scared and we
went to Congress when he said we'd
better have people believe in this so
let's get a bill through saying that the
Full Faith and Credit of the United
States has pledged to the insurance of
these deposits because in fact it is and
we don't want people to get scared and
we got a sense of the Congress
resolution to that effect we did not get
a law but the the it had begun insuring
deposits up to $2,500 in nineteen in
early 1980 the
was $40,000 in more on March 31st 1980
the Congress passed the law which raised
that to $100,000
and one of the interesting aspects of
that law is that that raise in the
deposit insurance minimum than the
insured deposit maximum rather was was
not in either the house or the Senate
bill coming into contracts it was added
in conduct at the the motion of Alan
Cranston and Livia California as well
page 20 of your book deposit insurance
has proved to be the crack cocaine of
American Finance yep why because well
let's let's take let's take a look at a
universe of banking and SNL's without
deposit insurance when a guy begins to
go under anybody with any brains gets
his money who who knows anything gets
his money out of that institution before
1980
even with Deposit Insurance any
institution that God in trouble would
get smaller because a there'd be people
who had money in it over the deposit
insurance maximum who would be in danger
would take it out and be there'd be
people who say this is a failing bank I
don't want to have my money in a failing
bank even if the government will pay me
back in the case of SNL's it wasn't an
immediate payback either so you even had
a financial reason even though you're
gonna get your money and the government
controlled the interest rates that these
guys could pay to get deposits so that
if if an institution began to go bad it
would get smaller there was a kind of
immune system to the banks in the S&L
that when a guy got sick he got smaller
and therefore the threat to the Deposit
Insurance Fund was limited you went in
1980 in 1982 and you freed up the
interest rates that they could all fix a
cuckoo bird or for any interest rate and
the government would pay it if other
people were paying 7% and you said I'll
pay 9% you could get money from them you
could get money from lives from from the
public easily you could also pay a
commission to a broker to bring it in
who freed up the interest rate ceiling
1980 1982 the first was the depository
institutions deregulation and monetary
Control Act in 1980 honest it'd it oh
yes Congress did it the second was the
gun st. germain Act in 1982 those two
the first of them said that we are going
to decontrol interest rates set up a
committee
regulators to do it gradually over seven
years the second of them said do it now
just free them up all right let me go
back to the connection here on the Garn
saint-germain act yeah Jake Garn a
senator from Utah yeah chairman of the
Senate Banking Committee at that at that
time when the Republicans had control
yeah Freddie st. Germain Democrat
chairman of the House Banking Committee
right now he got in some kind of trouble
he didn't get returned to Congress for
some reason earlier why is that well
because he had taken advantage of his
position as chairman of the Banking
Committee to make himself quite a rich
man on interest-free loans from from
people who had banks who were regulated
by regulators who was subject to freddie
st. Germain's authority there were there
were a number of stories in the Wall
Street Journal the House Ethics
Committee investigated they gave him a
slap on the wrist but the people of his
district decided they were sick of it
and he was one of the few congressmen in
recent years to lose one of the stories
that has is told about this which I tell
in the book is that when he knew he was
a loser when the polls came in saying
that he was a loser he pulled all of his
television commercials for the last week
of a cab paid and kept money because he
was one of those guys elected before
1980 who could do that legally all right
senator garnishee ever been accused of
taking God's months go on to decent guy
to the best of my knowledge I have I
have yeah the the thing that they say
about going around the Senate he's the
space senator he cared about that he's
the one who went up in the space shuttle
some of the people who work for him say
you never came down
he's a slightly Spacey senator we have
others it's there's no harm in having
slightly Spacey centers the thing that
if you if you read through the record of
the various hearings which Gaughan has
participated what you see is a guy who
is in fact pure in heart whose
understanding of these matters is not
that great but there's worse and who
wound up sponsoring things which he
later did not wish to believe had made
the trouble they made you know when you
when you talk about congressmen taking
money and doing things go on didn't do
that you talk about some of these other
guys I'm I'm a part-time music critic
and years ago salts all your ideas to
send all of the music critics to
little two-ounce joys of caviar at
Christmas and a bottle of vodka and
Martin Feinstein who runs the Washington
Opera now was then it's good good old
old friend was then Euro Express guy and
he said to Yurok once mr. Urich do you
really think that you can buy a good
review with too little to anse your eyes
of caviar and your ox of course not of
course not but there's two ways to write
a bad review and that's right and so
people make gifts to congressmen doesn't
mean that they're going to buy their
support but it doesn't mean that they're
going to get a different kind of hearing
when they come in with a problem so now
you get the S&L situation and you get
them buying the best accounting firms to
certify dishonest books let's be blunt
about at the SNL's to apply accounting
practices which the American Institute
of Certified Public Accountants has said
okay but the Financial Accounting
Standards Board has said in no way this
is a dishonest presentation there are
people who are leaders you would think
they would follow what the Standards
Board says but if they didn't have to if
the practice contradicted the theory and
the practice benefited a Charlie Keating
or a David Paul or a Michael wise or a
Tom Spiegel or all of these guys who
looted these SNL's for all about money
they would go along with them so then a
Spiegel or a wise or a Keating or a poor
would come to the congressman and he
would say the regulator's are picking on
me and here Arthur Young or Ernst &
Whinney or Arthur Andersen or or Coopers
and Lybrand all of the autor to Schwartz
all of these are implicated firms when I
give chapter and verse in the book of
the institutions that they that they
exerted accounting for him big the great
accounting firms of the world not just
of this country so so so this swindler
would would would come in with a
statement certified by a big eight
accounting firm he would be represented
by one of the nation's great law firms
paying the guy involved four hundred
dollars an hour to do it
and he says to this congressman to whom
he's making a contribution these stupid
regulators I'm misinterpreting the law
and pushing me around you got to help me
now later when it turns out the
regulators were right and these guys
were crooks the congressman is in terror
trouble but if you move him back to that
moment in time and if you read the
transcript of the of the meeting of the
Keating five with the San Francisco
people you have deacon Cheney for whom I
have no sympathy because Deacon Cheney
later on did things for Keating which
are disgraceful but at that moment he
said we have this statement from author
young this letter from author Young
senior accountant in Phoenix saying that
all of this is okay how do you account
for that
what a great accounting firm prostitute
itself and Mike Patriarca from the San
Francisco Home Loan Bank said they do it
every day but this but for his
congressman or a senator to realize that
these people whose names he respects and
years ago would have been right to
respect our prostituting themselves
judge judge sporkin castigated the law
firm of Kay shoulder from the bench here
Keating had sued to get his SNL back I
mean that joke lawsuits and sporkin took
it all seriously being a man of a sense
of humor and heard all the evidence and
then at the end he ruled that of course
this this improvidently run and
essentially crooked SNL was properly
seized by the government but at every
step in the way this 400-plus lawyer law
firm nationwide headquartered in New
York very distinguished people in it had
counsel Keating had helped him do all of
this and spoken excoriated them from the
bench and a spokesman for this law firm
said then though it not to me this is
something I took out of the papers but
I'll assume the papers are accurate we
did only what the client asked us to do
[ __ ] are not allowed to make that
defense why should a great law firm
think that that is a defense for having
done what they did Federal Home Loan
Bank board we go back to the beginning
of the rice dick Pratt former University
of Utah professor subsequently chairman
of Merrill Lynch mortgage capital moved
on
afterward after the Federal Home Loan
Bank we've done and made a lot of money
yeah I want to talk about him just a
second but also ed gray was a head of
that upper head gray succeeded Pratt in
the spring of 83
who succeeded ed gray Danny wall who
succeeded Danny wall well Danny Danny
wall became the first head of the office
of Thrift Supervision when the system
was reorganized and was then forced out
essentially by the House Banking
Committee and there's a man named
Timothy Ryan who is who is now the head
of the
for the fifth soup of it reason I'm
going through this is I want to get back
to talk about dick Pratt
dead great Danny well and so we can get
some sense of how as we watch speaker
right leave office over the relationship
with Ed gray and all that kind of stuff
we can get some sense of it
dick pratt again what what did he do
when he was in that job because you say
by the way you say in your book you
blame him for this whole SNL crew I say
if you're looking for any one person to
blame more than any other one person
it's got to be practice why because he
wrote the regulations in other words my
the basic position of this book is that
all of this was facilitated by the
change in the accounting procedures of
this industry which Pratt instituted in
1981 and 1982 savings opponent of Lee
Savings and Loan industry plus other
things for example when Pratt came in to
get a Deposit Insurance Charter you had
to have are you either be a mutual
institution had to have at least four
hundred shareholders and nobody could
control more than 25 percent of the
stock Pratt removed that restriction
when Pratt came in you couldn't have
more than five percent of your deposits
as brokered deposits you had to have
them coming in from real people at
teller windows Pratt removed that
restriction they are you couldn't play
in the options and futures markets
before Pratt came in
Pratt wrote regulations which permitted
these guys to play in the options and
the futures market I list them the best
list is in a book by a guy named ed Cain
was a professor at Ohio State book
published by the Urban Institute who has
page after page of the change in the
regulations which eliminated the immune
system of the industry and what Pratt
will say is that you know these were
regulations they could have been changed
later we never intended this to be
permanent just testified before the
House Banking Committee and said we
never intended these changes to be
permanent when the industry when the
interest rates came down they were all
to go away but the fact of the matter is
that when gray did try to change them
Pratt led the charge against the changes
because he was then working with Merrill
Lynch and Merrill Lynch was making a
fortune out of the SMS you also point
out that Don Regan chief of staff to
Ronald Reagan former Merrill Lynch CEO
yeah I was in this mix did he ever do
anything wrong ed gray says
and the people around grace a and Pratt
doesn't quite deny that at one
particular crisis moment when American
Savings and Loan of Stockton which was
the nation's largest S&L 30 billion
dollars big institution was going to go
under and they really had to raise money
to pay back the people who wanted their
money out ah pride agreed to put a
billion dollars of Merrill Lynch
customers money into American Savings
and Loan CDs and after talking to Don
Regan he backed away from it I do not
know this as a fact but every but
there's no question that Merrill Lynch
had been expected to put in the money
that Merrill Lynch backed away at the
last minute in the phone call from Pratt
to gray and that the bank board then had
to reach George ball of Prudential Beach
in Spain where he was on vacation to get
a billion dollars of Prudential base
money in there there's a book coming out
by nice guy named Michael Robinson who
was the American Bankers San Francisco
man which is a story of American Savings
and Loan is not yet and he tells this
story in some detail I tell it in the
page or two here I believe that Don
Regan probably did interfere at that
moment and then later on he was then
Secretary of the Treasury later on when
he became Regan's chief of Reagan's
chief of staff there's no question that
he belligerently interfered with the
operations of the Bank board and tried
to prevent the Bank board from
withdrawing the regulations out of which
these guys were making so much money 26
books yeah I guess that which one sold
the bet the bankers was a was a Book of
the Month Club main selection but year
1975 and they distributed 160,000 copies
and about 80,000 sold in the bookstores
and then Ballantine brought it out in
paper and it sold half a million that's
the one that sold the best the one that
sold the best in the book stores alone
was the lawyers in 1967 what was your
favorite book to write oh yeah
I mentioned as a part-time he was a
critic
I remember when Colin Davis would been a
horn player first became the conductor
the BBC Symphony anyone a little and I
interviewed him for column I was then
writing in Esquire magazine and he said
he was going to do the four Brahms
symphonies which he'd never done he'd
been playing in an opera house orchestra
and I said do you like the Bronx
Anthony's and he said to me that's your
business he said I played you decide
whether you like the river and I write
for a living I I enjoy writing most of
the time I enjoy the information
gathering and the analysis even more
really this book is is unique for me
though because I've never come out of a
book with him with the emotional
feelings about what I was writing about
that I have with this one this is a
great disgrace it says things about my
country that I don't like to believe it
says things about people whom I would
like to respect but I don't want to
believe ah I I think this is a this this
story is a terrible storm terrible story
about the way we run this country are
you worried I'm worried yes that's right
worried I guess is also could have I
have kids in two generation that kids
were 35 32 nine and six and the nine and
six year olds going to be paying for
this and my grandchildren are gonna be
paying for this and it was totally
unnecessary and it was because of the
piggish --mess of people who should have
some feeling of responsibility for this
society I don't blame the Cowboys
Cowboys accountable but Jerry good but
Adam Smith as a piece of film it shows a
grizzled Tech's big Texas hat and he's
saying look he's got a fox in a henhouse
get a lot of dead chickens doesn't mean
that's a bad Fox Fox gonna doing a head
you could have somebody keep the Fox out
of the henhouse
you let a builder own an SNL he'll cover
the earth with buildings he doesn't care
if they sell well he needs financing so
he can build you set the world up so he
has free financing from the S&L Eon and
there's no end to the building but I
don't blame you
not bad that's what he does we're
supposed to have regulations that keep
these guys from owning these and that's
true so that when you when you complain
about the dawn vixens of this world or
even the Charlie Maps all of look you
know even the heating's are separate so
heating is a great con man that's a
different game um and and Paul may be
too but a lot of these guys have cost
the public a lot of money and pristine
nature I don't blame them some of the
things that happened in Congress that's
the way the world works I don't blame
them but people who are professional
people who presumably have a code that
says you're supposed to behave better
than mere legality their collaboration
and cooperation
that's what scandal Eisenmann shocks me
where'd you grow up New York City yeah
my father was a lawyer my father started
life in one of the big Wall Street firms
I wrote a biography of the guy who was
his first boss at the request of Felix
Frankfurter who had been this guy's best
friend and you know what was always true
that there were feet of clay in a lot of
these idols and a lot of guys who worked
the senior partners of Wall Street
houses in the tens and twenties and
thirties did things they shouldn't have
done but nevertheless the judgment
leadership in the profession was whether
somebody embodied the whether somebody
embodied the ideal of that profession
and and spoke to what people wanted to
think of themselves as members of that
profession I you were a leader you had
an obligation to set standards so then
you got to be a leader in a profession
by having the highest fees that's a
terrible loss to this country where'd
you go terrible was I went too hard what
you study economic I was I was there in
the great days I had causes with Joseph
Schumpeter and what Seeley Leon EF was
my tutor but I got out very early I
didn't like education terribly much and
I finished Harvard before my 19th
birthday graduated yeah that's a good
question no I was I was in trouble and
it wasn't until I was about 20 that I
actually got my diploma but I had
finished my full I had finished the full
program except I hadn't passed my
language requirement yet I went out
in Italian in order to get a degree but
I did not actually graduate until the
spring of 48 I guess when I was 20 but I
finished in January 47 just before my
19th birthday I took my last exam at
Harvard well here in the language
what year tonight 40 right the first
book the first book well I wrote a
couple of novels and nobody published
had a good thing to I'd be pretty
embarrassed the first books came out in
55
there was a novel called the experts and
there was a book called Wall Street men
and money which was kept in print for
another 18 years by Collier books it boy
was it out of date when they finally
junked it it was a great title wasn't my
diet with Tom Morgan stock did you know
even though you got a degree in
economics that you were gonna write for
a living well I guess so I mean I began
writing a good friend of mine and I in
fourth grade put out a newspaper and my
father's memory a graft machine and I
was always editing school papers and I
was on what was the Harvard service news
when I was first there but then the
Harvard Crimson again what the end of my
time and my first job out of out of
school was the New York Journal of
Commerce which was going to combine the
economics and the writing I had thought
for a while it's gonna be an economist
but Professor Leon he have said to me
one day you don't use mathematics to
solve problems I said what'd he mean he
said you decide what you want to say and
then you find equations that say it and
I said of course does anybody do
anything else and he said yes he said
but what you're supposed to do is set up
the problem mathematically insolvent
mathematically and I that had never
occurred to me and I suddenly realized
what I couldn't do that I I've been very
lucky there were things that I was
tempted to do with somebody pointed out
to me you are no good so I didn't do him
and then back in the early 80s just the
Ronald Reagan's Housing Commission yeah
you served on that for how long I was a
commissioner it was a one-year thing and
and you know we met in the year counting
the subcommittees and the Finance
Committee's and such things I suppose I
put in a total of 40 days and then I
read I mean I wrote the executive
summary that was that's a great way to
wash
story now you served you got paid $200 a
day for the time actually spent in
meetings I mean the reading that you did
and other things that you might do and
connect with the Commission you didn't
get paid for it was it was not a good
investment of time but I wanted to to do
it was interesting and useful experience
and one thought one was being helpful to
one's country first time he'd ever done
anything like no I'd been a member of
the president's panel on educational
research and development in the Kennedy
and Johnson administration when I was
working in education and that was for
five years and that was the first Monday
and Tuesday of every month but that's
these were the two I've also been on
office of Technology Assessment panels
I've been in and out I've testified but
but this was this was a little different
and anyway so bill McKenna who was the
chairman came to me one of the last
meetings and said you know we'd like
people to be able to read the executive
summary we don't want it done in
bureaucratese it's about 50 pages would
you write it for us and I said yes but
I'm gonna do that somebody has to pay me
for it because I just can't afford it I
got too little I got was that one little
kid and I and I cannot give you an
enormous amount of writing time and
that's at least a month's work a 50 page
executive summary what'd I tell you what
I'll do I'll go to a foundation and so
the government doesn't have to pay and
I'll have the Foundation give the money
to the Department of Housing and Urban
Development to pay to me for for writing
the 50 page summary as a professional
job you know we said commissioners are
not supposed to be paid for their work
on the Commission I said to him build
your an SNL lawyer
Mauri man is is with Merrill Lynch
mortgage capital Pete herder is a real
tour with the National Association of
Realtors and I ran down all the other
people on the Commission every one of
you guys has party pre here every one of
you was representing clients were
building his own business we're working
in this and I haven't seen anybody give
up his own side of this in any of these
meetings I'm the only guy here who does
not make any money out of this industry
and who does not have any stake whatever
and what this this commission says and
you tell me it's a conflict of interest
for me to get paid by a foundation for
my time to write the executive summary a
builder was a very decent guidance
father was a man who worked in the
sewers and then and and it's him he's
he's he's not one of these rockefeller
types who thinks everybody has enough
money all the time thought about it and
he said you're right in this case we
could wave kind of money they paid yeah
I think I got $7,000 it went through the
Smith Richardson foundation which was
very acceptable to the Reagan
administration I had done they had been
people who were interested with the
sloan foundation in sponsoring possible
television series for me which in the
light and so I knew them I knew the
people there and I called them and I
said this is a job that they want me to
do and I really can't afford to give
this time away could you would you be
willing to make a grant to HUD for HUD
to pay me and they said sure they made
the grant the HUD took about eight
months to pay me much but they but they
did pay it was our the 7,000 was over
seventy five hundred dollars it was not
that bad it was not that bad a payment
for the time the experience you saw
government up-close
of course you'd done these other things
in government what do you think of the
process I know I sort of like the
Constitution I think it could work a lot
better than it's then it's now working
ah somebody asked me a while ago what if
I could reform the government what's the
first thing I would do when I said sort
of one-third as a joke
but two-thirds not I would repeal a
unified budget act of 1921
there was no unified budget in this
country until 1921 the department's of
government submitted their requests
separately to the Congress and the
Congress had to make a budget item we
came out of the first world war when
that hadn't worked tell well the
president's involvement was as commander
in chief he submitted the the budgets
for the Armed Forces but for the all the
other departments of government they did
it themselves and then Congress made a
budget out of it that's what Congress is
paid to do the view you moved from the
budget bureau to the Office of
Management and Budget to the present
situation where the executive branch is
trying to make all these decisions and
considers itself not just one of the
players but the prime player that's not
the way our constitute
she's written the Constitution is
written that money bills originate my
house
budgets would have been made in the
house the house becomes irresponsible
the government becomes irresponsible
when when parts of its slough off to
other parts what their constitutional
responsibilities are in the case of you
know in this in the in the S&L scandal I
blame the media a lot to be honest with
you if if if this story had been covered
if when an SNL goes under big SNL with
some degree of scandal if the press
published the name of their lawyers if
the press published the name of their
accountants if you know sunshine remains
the best disinfectant that's one of the
reasons I have all these names in this
book I think you have to be responsible
for what you do I sign what I do with
all with all that's wrong with my
profession it isn't a profession it's a
trade I sign it I get my scars on the
front of my face I'm sure the audience
that's it what this book looks like this
is Martin Mayer's book it's his 26 the
greatest ever bank robber at least 26 we
can count the collapse of the Savings
and Loan industry and speaking of my 26
um opus I used to say if you're right
three pages a day it's a thousand pages
the inner he was better than I am but 26
books sounds like a lot of books but
this there's a year or two in each other
how long have you worked on this book I
signed the contracts in 88 about two
when you are at the last word that were
reading
well the afterword was written in July
there's a 12 page section at the end
which they gave me a chance to write at
the end to comment about what had been
happening otherwise it was written I
guess in voyage let me read this the
books written on this subject this is
your book your words page 19 the books
written on this subject today have been
rather like the famous story of the
Indian blind man describing elephant one
sees the Mafia one sees the Texas
Cowboys infecting the whole country with
financial aids once these regulators
goofing off once he's a malfunction from
the continuation of inadequate laws into
an era when they became destructive all
of this is true up to a point and of
course there's nothing wrong with
telling the stories which are great fun
in themselves what's different
your book than just telling these other
stories like will be good well I'm
dealing with the with the systemic
problem here at least I hope I am and
you're saying their accountants and
lawyers and elected officials there's
something deeply wrong with all those
I'm saying to begin with in the simplest
way to tell what happened here they say
the government in 81-82 had a very bad
problem connected with fight with with
the financing of housing we had a lot of
institutions that had long term
mortgages that were yielding 6 7 8 9 %
at a time when these institutions had to
pay for new money anyway 11 12 13 % ah a
decision was made that these
institutions could grow out of this
problem they could add enough very high
yielding assets so that they could pay
on the marginal money enough they could
make money at the end of it since they
had a certain amount of money that was
still an endowment of five and a half
percent passbook savings if you if you
structured the world so that they could
get more money because they could
advertise higher interest rates they
could then make new loans at even higher
interest rates and make enough money so
they can make up for what they were
losing on the old one and the industry
could in general grow out of it and when
interest rates came down a bit it would
be profitable and strong this was a
mistake I am NOT going to criticize the
people who made the mistake it was a
desperate time I remember sitting around
in these meetings and we were counting
the number of months until the whole
industry went bust and you couldn't say
but anymore so these accounting rakes
that Pratt put him were for the purpose
of enabling people to hang on until they
could grow out dick pratt head of the
Federal Home Loan Bank board um but this
was a mistake because the basic problem
in the SNL industry was over capacity
when we sat on the Housing Commission we
looked at how you financed housing I was
on the Finance Committee and one of the
things that jumped out of the historical
record is that in the 1920s and in
indeed right after World War 2 20% plus
of home mortgages in the United States
were held
my life insurance companies and by 1980
they held no mortgages meanwhile the
savings of the country were moving from
a depository chassis that is from
deposits and banks and SNL's to a
contract chassis that is payments to
pension funds life insurance companies
mutual funds so that and these people
these recipients of household savings
were not buying mortgages so we said we
have to design instruments that will
help the contract thrift as we call them
begin to get into housing finance this
will provide more money for housing
remember we're a Housing Commission we
have a parochial view and we'll provide
that at lower cost which everybody wants
the American people will be able to get
better housing cheap what was not in
Armagh - things were not in our minds
one was that we were going to be putting
pressure on what the SNL's could earn
because they'd be competitive for buying
mortgages and therefore the spread
between the cost of money and what
mortgages got the spread between what
corporations had to pay in bonds and
what people who bought homes had to pay
in mortgages would be reduced and the
long term viability of the industry
would diminish because it would have
more competitors for its own business
and the second thing we didn't think
about was that we were structuring very
complicated instruments to bring in
these guys and the Wall Street has which
screw around with those experts for
their own benefit so that some of it
would be junk and they would and they
would sell the junk to the SNL's and
they would they would trade bits of
glass with the natives to their own
immense profit which is what the Wall
Street houses did they would broker in
the funds they'd get paid big
commissions for brokering in the funds
and then they'd sell them the
collateralized mortgage obligations and
different tranches and you don't want to
know the details we I give as little as
I can in the book because I think people
have to understand some of this
understand what what happened but it's a
very complicated story so those things
happen meanwhile we had an industry that
had 700 billion dollars of deposits its
social function was shrinking because
others were going to provide a lot of
the mortgage we said you can grow out of
it we grew it up to 1.4 trillion
we're lucky that the losses are only a
hundred and seventy billion
it was a mistake you should not have
tried to grow this industry out of its
problems it had to shrink you had to
take some losses and shrink it we
weren't entirely the wrong way in a
capitalist system you couldn't grow an
industry that was failing but we don't
have a capitalist system in banking we
have a government guaranteed system
through Deposit Insurance therefore the
government could structure things so
that these guys could grow by saying
that we will we will guarantee whatever
interest you promised they could grow so
the government set this up the market
would have killed these guys if if that
if they'd been a free-market SNL's would
have failed money would have fled the
industry and the industry would have
shrunk willy nilly with possibly great
damage to the yes so to the society the
job was to shrink it without damage
instead we grew it with immense cost now
by 1971 by 1984 it was pretty clear that
this is what was happening you could see
the losses building credit of Ed Gray
who was Pratt's successor at the Bank
board and if you measured IQs is well
below dik dik prat but he's a decent guy
certain amount of common sense and and
and he cared about his job and he felt
responsible for what was happening work
by the way let me ask you dick pratt
left for what reason he went he had said
he would serve two years he went out to
make money how did that gray get his job
where'd he come from ed gray had been
Ronald Reagan's press secretary when he
was governor of California and he had
worked in the Reagan campaign when
Reagan became president he became the
first director of the domestic policy
group at the White House then he went
back to California because his wife
hated Washington he got a job with great
American Savings and Loan
Gordon loose it was a friend of the
presidents and they wanted somebody who
would not make waves or disturb things
to become the head of the Bank board
after pratt and who would keep all the
Platt quote reforms close quote in being
and they reached out for ed and Ed was a
little flattered he had he had been a
reporter for the United Press he'd been
a radio guy he'd been a speechwriter
this was going to be a chance to have
executive authority and a big job he
took the job and he did
very best he could with it and I admire
Edgar he never had experience with
banking or savings he never had
experience with running no he'd worked
for an SNL he worked in the press
department how long did he stay at the
Federal Home Loan Bank he stayed his
full term of four years he tried hard
alright somewhere in the book you talk
about he'd never run anything you
understand me that was part of the
problem also he had to organize
something for new set of tasks get
trouble doing that he didn't have
Pratt's understanding of this industry
though it grew it grew in that job and I
respect and I and I like John Gray it is
an honest man a lot of people don't like
it and when I when the Wall Street
Journal said I was working on this book
a lot of people who used to work at the
bag boardwalk lot six of them got hold
of me and said don't let a great rewrite
history but the fact is that grey began
shouting that there were troubles when
it was very unpopular to do so he tried
to make changes he didn't know which
changes he wanted to make ah um he
didn't handle it well in some ways but
he tried and he was an honest man and I
think he deserves a lot of credit he's
getting it now for what go let me ask
you about something you said 170 billion
in losses because of the savings alone
in this book though you talk about where
Charles Bowser who's the Comptroller of
the United States and had great set
around betting how big this loss was
gonna be yeah and Ed gray said it was
gonna be bigger they get a billion no
nobody says the loss is 500 billion
present value present value with maybe
I say 150 I think it's now lean season
Siemens handling the bailout so badly
it's now up to 170 and if we continue
running the Resolution Trust Corporation
the way we are we'll get to 200 very
soon to a major present value if you tax
people to pay it out now it would be
let's say a hundred and seventy billion
dollars that's a lot of money but if
you're going to borrow to take care of
it then you got to add in the interest
that you pay on the borrowings so then
let's assume it's eight percent interest
that you're gonna put in nine years it
doubles in 18 years it quadruples by the
rule of 72 so that it's it's a question
of what time are you going to pay it
back on how much interest you're going
to pay
you can get to 500 billion very easily
if you want to look at the 2020 you can
get it up to 600 billion the present
value of the losses what has been lost
not what you're going to pay interest on
later but what has been lost is probably
somewhere between 150 and 200 though it
may get worse there's a lot more in this
book and we're running out of time and I
want to ask you about something that's
in the appendix it's Appendix C in 1985
February the 13th you have a letter in
here from Alan Greenspan ago and it's
about the Lincoln Savings & Loan
Association it's about Charles Keating I
want to ask you that on February the
13th 1985 what was the public knowledge
about the Lincoln Savings alone the
public knowledge was that the with the
Federal Home Loan Bank board had decided
that that direct investment by SNL's was
dangerous Alicia the San Francisco
people who supervise Lincoln Savings and
Loan had found that mr. Keating had put
far more than the legal maximum into a
into a fight for the control of golf
broadcasting that he had put money into
Ivan Boesky that he had stopped writing
home loan home mortgages though he had
said he was going to the SNL he had
bought was the largest supplier of
mortgages to the black and hispanic
populations of southern california he
had withdrawn from that business he had
closed his branches in lower
middle-class neighborhoods and he was
putting money into very risky things his
own developments Gulf Broadcasting
Bosque a lot of Mike Milken stuff for
Drexel Burnham and the Bank board was
concerned about him and was trying to
rein him in his his lawyer then was
Arthur Lyman who would presently become
the lawyer for the Senate in the are in
the iran-contra affair mr. Lyman and he
recruited beef B for Lyman professor
George Benson of the University of
Rochester to an academic dissertation on
why direct investment was right and
Keating should be left alone and this
was considered by mr. Lyman to be
insufficient to persuade the feds
mr. Lyman went and paid alan greenspan
who was been a private consultant
$40,000 essentially to write a letter in
Keating support to the Federal Home Loan
Bank of San Francisco it would have been
possible I would say
fairly easy to determine that a number
of the statements in that letter were
false at that time okay Alan Greenspan
is now the chairman of the Federal
Reserve more very competent what I would
say I disagree with this and that but
Alan is not a bad guy the problem in
this book is not the people who are bad
guys that doesn't bother them that you
always get bad guys it's what the good
guys did because the standards will I
just want to read some of this because
this comes from the current chairman of
the Federal Reserve Board at the time
what a consult I don't know he was then
a private consultant whose services were
for sale but presumably he was an honest
man all right you writes a very sad
letter I run it with me okay yeah do it
I have read I have reviewed the
application Lincoln has submitted to
your office this is to the office of the
principle supervisor agent Federal Home
Loan Bank Ford or Federal Home Loan Bank
in San Francisco and it is my opinion
that Lincoln clearly merits the
exemption it seeks one Lincoln's new
management and that of its parent
American Continental corporation is
seasoned and expert in selecting and
making direct investments to the new
management has a long and continuous
track record of outstanding success in
making sound and profitable direct
investments three the new management
succeeded in a relatively short period
of time and reviving an association that
had become badly burden on and on and on
all fourth awful why because he believed
what his client told him that's because
he didn't look he was he was he was
rapping with the mantle of his
reputation somebody who was a crook and
a swindler
that's what's so troubles he's mr.
keating guilty of anything he thing I
think gonna wind up in jail but segolia
he's a great con man well he stole 40
million bucks the last day before they
seize the institution forty million
dollars moved out through Bankers Trust
the parts unknown the ribby and I think
why didn't he use the money then to get
him out when he had a fight because he
doesn't want to omit he's got it I mean
nobody knows where that money went
nobody's subpoenaed Bankers Trust
records Federal Reserve Board would have
a bleeding hemorrhage if anybody did but
we should Charlie Charlie Keating was
engaged in a large number of crooked
activities while he ran Lincoln Savings
and Loan and you know he's been indicted
now for swindling these old people in
California he will be indicted again on
federal
charges I think Keating will eventually
go to jail I think he should go to jail
you say in this book you talk about
accountants you name all the big
accounting at all the big accounting by
all the big law firms on the Anderson
did file stuffing for Keating but God's
a matter of premise you have here then
you name the chairman of the Federal
Reserve Board what is wrong with this
country that's the question the book
asks in the end do you have an answer
yeah well there's a that my favorite
line in my own book one always has a
favorite line and once I wouldn't have a
favorite book but one has a favorite
line is that the 1980s were a time when
the government conspired so that the
pigs could get what used to be the
lion's share I have I have I I'm a
believer in capitalist economies I'm a
believer in markets what we did in this
wing was Jim it was Jim Tobin of Yale
who first described it I believe as
socializing the losses and privatizing
the gains it became the only standards
of judgment we seem to have by the time
the eighties were halfway through was
how much money did he did he make
there's been a there's been an erosion
of moral fiber and ethical sense in this
country how you reverse it I don't know
but that's what's there disturb why
about it why did it happen what's
causing well I suppose you know I was
active in education in the sixties and
there was all this stuff about never
trust anybody over 30 and I used to say
to these kids when I would travel around
they traveled around for the sloan
Foundation and for some others visiting
colleges on various studies that I would
do I would say to them you're right but
you don't seem to understand why the
generation that came out of World War
two the people who had lived through the
depression and then World War two felt
they were going to get theirs after the
war they structured the world on and
what is a very unfair basis
intergenerationally the kids who were in
college in the sixties they the kids of
the baby boom had been cheated really
they're not gonna get the Social
Security that their parents got they're
not gonna get a lot of other things the
whole way the the seniority systems were
set up in the unions the way everybody
protected himself and this came out of
the
we're talking things far beyond
economics it came out of I think the
experiences of the generation that ran
the country finally in the 80s the
people who who turned the age where they
were in authority had been brought up in
an atmosphere of grasping this in the
50s and I think that we have to blame
that more than anything else the
question is how do you turn it around
how do you restore some notion of
citizenship in a country like this one
and I don't I would hope look does well
enough I'll have some time to try to
think about it and maybe I'll have I'll
have something worth worth hearing on it
when it's over anything's possible I'm
not sure I have anything worth hearing
on it now but it's it's it's a serious
problem I chewed out some academics the
other day but there that the kids come
out of the business schools now with so
little sense of what constitutes
standards of behaviour how much time do
we have got two minutes for a story
thank you sir 60 second this is this is
this is about a guy who said to me that
when he went to work on Wall Street
sometimes people would say to him we
don't do that that's what that's a deal
we don't do he said it's been 20 years
since I've heard anybody said say we
don't do that we've got to get back to a
sense of for my self-respect I don't do
that maybe you can find somebody else to
do it maybe it isn't illegal but I don't
do I have too much pride to - we're
doing losing that is the really
dangerous thing and that's really what
this is they're our guests for the last
60 minutes has been Martin Maher this is
what the book looks like it's published
by scriveners it sells for 2250 you can
find it in your bookstores thank you sir
thank you